- You might remember
that in the early 2000's
there was an effort to
rebrand French fries
as freedom fries, a
lexical act of vengeance
for France's opposition to
the US-led invasion of Iraq.
Not such a sick burn considering
it's probably the Belgians,
not the French, who deserve credit
for America's favorite side dish.
That wasn't the first time
a war provoked a food name change.
During World War I,
German imports like
sauerkraut and frankfurters
were renamed liberty
cabbage and liberty sausage.
Let's hope we don't go
to war with Italy again,
because I am not calling
a pizza a freedom Frisbee.
Apparently, rebranding
foods over political gripes
does not work because none
of these monikers stuck.
But many food etymologies
have even stranger stories.
Some are passed down
over thousands of years,
some invented by marketing wizards,
and some are so mysterious, we
can only guess their origins.
Let's dig to some interesting
histories of food words.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky
and this is "Otherwords."
(bright music)
- [Announcer] "Other Words."
- The word food comes
from the Proto-Indo-European
root pa, to feed.
It's also where we get
pantry, pastor and company.
And surprisingly, many
of the oldest human foods
have names that are shared
among many languages.
Corn, for example,
originally just referred
to any type of cereal grain,
and still retains that meaning
in some English-speaking countries.
In fact, corn and grain
have the same root.
The native American staple
that the Taino people called mahiz
was nicknamed Indian corn by Europeans,
which in the US was eventually
shortened to just corn.
In the UK, it's known by
the Anglicized version
of a Spanish interpretation
of the Taino word, maize.
Because of their similarity to grains,
the small berries of the Piper
plant were called peppercorns
which are dried and ground
to make black pepper.
This was a very popular
seasoning in the old world,
reflected by cognates in many languages.
In fact, finding a new
source of peppercorns
was one of the reasons the
Spanish monarchy bankrolled
Christopher Columbus's
voyage across the Atlantic.
What he found instead
were the chilis of
Mexico and the Caribbean.
In what may have been a devious
bit of colonial marketing,
he renamed them peppers, hoping
to cash in on the popularity
of black pepper back home.
Though they share a name in
a penchant for spiciness,
chili peppers and black pepper
are botanically unrelated.
Oddly enough, English has
different names for animals
depending on whether
they're alive or dead.
As we mentioned in a previous episode,
this is thanks to the
French-speaking Normans
who conquered England in the 11th century.
When English farmers raised livestock,
they called them pigs, cows, and sheep.
But when the French nobles
ordered them served on a platter,
they called it porc, beof and moton.
Venison, the word for deer meat,
came from the old French venesoun,
which roughly meant "the
meat that was just hunted."
A lot of dish names are accidentally
or deliberately misleading
about what's in them.
Sweetbreads, for instance,
are not bread at all,
but cooked glands, usually
from calves or lambs.
The bread part may come
from the old English brǣd,
meaning flesh or meat.
Head cheese is not a cheese,
but a loaf of meat made
from a cow or pig's head
minced up and packed
together with gelatin.
And Rocky Mountain
oysters are not oysters,
but the deep fried testicles
of bulls, pigs or sheep.
After hearing those three, you
might be frightened to know
what's really in Welsh rabbit,
but it's actually just
melted cheese on toast.
Some say the name was created
by the British to be an insult.
Wales was considered to be so poor
that their rabbit had no rabbit in it.
More recently, capitalism
has forced the food industry
to be very deliberate about
what they call their products
to attract the most customers.
For example, kiwis are
actually native to China,
but when they were first imported
to New Zealand in the early 20th century,
the sellers knew that míhóutáo and qíyìguô
wouldn't roll easily off
English speakers' tongues.
Since they were from China
and tasted a bit like gooseberries,
they named them, drum roll, please.
Da-da-da.
Chinese gooseberries.
(triumphant music)
But when Chinese gooseberries
finally made it to America 50 years later,
they didn't sell so well.
And the importers blamed the name.
First, they tried melonettes,
since they looked kind
of like little melons,
and then finally settled on kiwifruits,
named after the adorable
fuzzy birds of New Zealand.
Third time's the charm.
The fruits took off,
and the name was eventually
shortened to kiwis.
The ocean is full of lots
of weird-looking creatures
with unappetizing names.
If you're a fisherman
who catches slimeheads,
toothfish, rockfish or lizardfish,
it might help your sales
to use a different name on the menu.
How about orange roughy, Chilean sea bass,
Pacific snapper, or even Bombay duck?
And since the name dolphinfish might make people worry
that they're about to
chow down on Flipper,
you can call it mahi mahi instead,
a Hawaiian term for "very strong."
Last but definitely not least, sea urchin,
a delicacy known as uni in Japan
were once known as whore's eggs.
No one knows why, but I
think we can all agree
sea urchin is a big improvement.
In 2000, the FDA approved
the California Prune Board's
request to rebrand the
prune to the dried plum.
Why?
Because of their digestive benefits,
prunes had come to be associated
with elderly people and bowel problems,
two things advertisers
don't like to mention
when they're marketing
towards the cool kids.
Did it work?
Sales improved almost immediately,
especially among younger demographics.
Prunes were finally having
their moment in the sun.
Well, I guess they always did.
Recently, they decided to switch
back to the original name,
likely because health trends have changed,
and today, having regular bowel movements
is, like, totally cool, dude.
(upbeat music)
Two of the most popular
culinary imports from Mexico,
tacos and burritos,
have names whose origins
remain mysterious.
The original meaning
of a Spanish word taco
is a plug or a stopper,
perhaps related to the English word tack.
Some propose that Mexican silver minors
borrowed the term from the
plugs of explosives they used.
Gun powder wrapped in a paper tortilla.
(exploding)
Though tacos can be explosive
depending on how many
jalapenos are in them,
some have pointed out
that a mahiz flatbread
stuffed with filling
probably predates gun
powder in the Americas.
So it's more likely that the word came
from the Nahuatl word tlahco,
which meant in the middle,
because you put the filling
in the middle of the tortilla.
Burrito means little donkey in Spanish,
but it's not clear why that
term became applied to food.
It might be because burritos are filled
with so many different
things like a donkey's cargo,
or maybe it's a reference
to the shape of the bundles.
One very specific theory suggests
that during the Mexican Revolutionary War,
the inventor of the
burrito would sell them
from a little donkey-pulled cart.
Like many food etymologies,
we'll have to take this
one with a grain of salt.
From sweet breads to kiwis,
there's a clear trend
of dressing up our food
with names that are
attractive and exciting,
which makes sense,
because food is such a
pleasurable, communal experience.
It shouldn't matter
what our food is called
as long as it tastes good,
but no one's gonna stay for dinner
if you're serving
slimehead in prune sauce.
Maybe Shakespeare was right when he said,
"A rose by any other name
would smell a sweet."
But under a different
name, people might not stop
and smell the thornblotches.
Need more tasty food shows in your life?
Head over to the PBS Food YouTube channel
to check out "Relish."
It's hosted by the
delightful chef Yia Vang,
who explores different cultures
through our favorite dishes
in the universal language of food.
From dumplings and tortas
to grandma's pot roast,
this show is going to make you hungry.
You probably shouldn't watch
it on an empty stomach.
Check out "Relish" on PBS Food
in the link in the description.
Finding a new source of pepper
corns was one of the reasons
the Spanish monarchy--
Bankrolled.
What the--
But the bread part may come
from the old English broad--
Bread?
Brede.